in Cumbria close to the Scottish border
this is Britain's secret weapon in the
climate change fights these peatlands
with their mosses and their grasses
played a vital role in filtering carbon
from the air they're our equivalent of
rainforests in the UK or in the template
temperate climate they cover about 3% of
the world's surface but in that 3% they
actually cover they could they contain
more carbon than all the other habitats
put together but for years
peat has been dug up used as compost and
sold two gardeners and farmers both
amateur and professional and once it's
gone
Pete's carbon storage properties are
lost these sites took an awful long time
they took 10,000 years to form
I mean we've lost probably about 94 95
percent of our peatlands to forestry
agriculture burning grazing and
extraction commercial extraction of peat
for horticulture ten years ago the
Department for the environment set a
target that by 2020 Pete would no longer
be used in garden products for amateur
gardeners they're things like compost
that you can buy in the garden centre
and it had hoped that industry would be
well on the way to phasing out the use
of peat as well but those targets were
voluntary and they've been missed
we found peat based compost still on the
shelves of major garden centres and in
the medium that plants were grown in
being cute old us we are moving away
from Pete in our products we also sell
Pete free composter more competitive
prices and other composts whilst Dhabi's
said we are committed to being p3 for
2021 but they admitted even their
reformulated compost contains 30% peat
for many the industry is simply not
moving fast enough we need to really
decide that he's gonna be bummed and you
know let's see being bummed here in the
Lake District Simon bland is making peat
free compost it's a mix of local Bracken
and wool from Simon sheep but it is more
expensive to make than simply digging up
heat - there are slimmer profits for
producers and less financial incentives
for industry's biggest players it's
getting driven by the big companies are
supplying the material but you know the
garden centers they're they're buying
all these different things to put put to
the public - by the garden center should
be taking more responsibility
the department for the environment told
us that amateur gardeners should play
their part by switching to peat free
alternatives but environmentalists
believe it's up to the government to put
more pressure on suppliers to ensure
that Pete doesn't get put in a bag but
stays in a bog Caterina potosi Sky News
in Cumbria